thank you
let us lose this weekend
I thought
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
300 000 people in mariopal uh without
food it's not the war anymore
and in The Siege City
we clearly see that Russia wants to
start hunger just to enforce its
diplomatic position on the Diplomatic
processes
and what that Russia does
I've seen Medics wounded by Russian
Rifle rounds probably the worst thing I
saw were a stabilization point which
used to be a true children's hospital
um quite far north in fact it's probably
quite close to where we are now
probably further west but um we had a
Russian artillery shell go off about 100
meters from the hospital building blew
out all the windows
that was quite a stark realization of
how little of a dam the Russians give
about the ukrainians
[Music]
we are now on the brink of survival
Ukraine for Russian troops is the
Gateway into Europe where they want to
break in but this barbarism must be
stopped there are Russian troops who are
killing and raping people and kidnapping
children torturing people and looting
you know who brought this war to Ukraine
those who are supporting this war all of
them are using Italy as a place for
holidays so please don't be a holiday
resort to murderers